- [Off Camera] This is so sick!
- Woo!
(techno music)
♪ Go ♪
(screams)
(slow piano music)
- It's really (beep)-ing high up here.
Nobody said that it
was gonna be this high.
(upbeat music)
- So we are here right now
at Slotzilla.
(Daysha groans)
We're about to go off the
top, and Daysha's so excited.
- Yeah, there's a lot of
excitement on my face right now.
- Have you ever ziplined before?
- No, I've never ziplined.
I'm slightly nervous, but I also
don't wanna let my fears hold me back.
I'm just here and I'm gonna
do it and I might black out
but that's okay. (laughs)
- I had no idea that it looks like this,
but like, literally you're lying down
and then they, like,
open the gates of wrath
and then you go.
That's a little bit terrifying to me.
You ready for this?
- Yeah, let's do it.
- Wait, we have to do it again.
Okay, boom.
♪ "Eine kleine Nachtmusik"
by Wolfgang Amadeus Mozart ♪
- I'm gonna be cussing the whole time.
(pop)
- When I was little
and I swam in the pool,
I would go to the very surface
and pretend like I was flying,
and I feel like that's what
this is gonna be like now
but in real life,
and it's gonna be all my
childhood dreams come true.
(Daysha playfully cries)
- We just lay down? Oh
my God, it's moving!
(pop)
(Daysha laughs, Lizz groans)
- How is this my job?
(groans)
- Okay, I'm just gonna act
real tough, like I got this.
(screaming and laughing)
(techno music)
- [Off Camera] Oh my God, this is so sick!
(screaming and cheering)
- [Off Camera] Oh my God.
- [Lizz] I don't even,
I can't feel my face.
- That was so cool!
- It was like the closest I've ever felt
to flying like Superman.
It was like when I was a kid, in the pool.
Like, that's what it
felt like, but real life.
- I hate that I was so scared,
'cause it's so much fun.
- That part at the end is the worst.
- [Daysha] Yeah, that, honestly.
- [Lizz] When they just like, pshh.
Oh my God!
- I feel like I'm about
to drop every single time.
But I'm so glad I didn't let
my fears get the best of me.
I could do this all day, honestly.
And I'm someone that has a fear of depth
or height or whatever you wanna call it.
Like, looking down from very high points
scares the shit outta me, and I love this.
Like, I have to now
zipline throughout my life.
- Can we zipline to the car?
- Yeah!
Woosh!
- [Lizz] Woo!
- [Daysha] I'm ready to go again.
- [Lizz] Let's do it.
(techno music)